Never read on your friends and always
keep your mouth shut.
If you elevate loyalty over trip,
you've got a situation like barry bonds,
personal trainer,
Greg Anderson.
He was initially questioned about
whether he gave steroids,
are injected barry bonds with steroids.
He law and he said he never did.
Then when called before the grand jury,
he refused to testify.
He was held in contempt of court.
He was put in jail on multiple occasions
for remaining silent and one,
one of those occasions when he was
released from jail,
all the inmates gathered around and gave
him a standing ovation.
Well,
this to me pretty much says it all.
Loyalty over truth means this is the
code of the prison yard.
This is the code of organized crime.
This is the code of the Mafia.
Yes,
they weren't going to prosecute use of
steroids,
but they wanted to nail this guy for
distributing it.
So Barry bonds was called before the
grand jury.
He had been given immunity.
The only thing he could be prosecuted
for perjury or false statements,
he took the oath.
They then ask him,
did you use steroids?
No.
Were you ever injected with steroids?
He lied repeatedly to the grand jury.
Why did it take eight years from the
time that barry bonds allegedly lodge to
the grand jury until he was actually
tried for the case?
It was because everyone was long.
In that case,
it was worldclass lying on a massive
scale,
and all the prosecutors could do was
investigate people for perjury where
they couldn't get to the underlying
crimes.
Loyalty,
loyalty to one's employer.
Loyalty to a benefactor is a very
powerful countervailing force.
There must be some kind of punishment
and accountability in an ancient Rome.
People were put to death in medieval
England.
They had their tongues cut out.
I'm not saying we need to go to,
is that barbaric?
Extreme,
but there must be visible accountability
for breaking the law.
Yeah.